let me let me tell you where we're at my
friends we got the story i want to pull
up
quote we need to stiffen our spines and
lean in to keeping people safe
and healthy governor newsom says his
recall success proves democrats need to
get tougher with covert restrictions
so there can be peace awesome they're
going to give us that last part i added
that wasn't in the headline
but uh yeah so basically what happened
was uh since the recall failed
gavin newsom stood up before the the
state legislature in california and says
the attempt on my governorship has left
me scarred and deformed and i will
reform california into the first you
know
cal state state state empire it's just
the government's responsibility to keep
us safe that's not their job that's not
what they that's not what they've been
tasked to do by the voters that's not
what they were tasked to do by
you know the founding fathers who all
managed to find themselves in the same
place at the exact right time but here's
here's the issue
they tried to recall newsome and a bunch
of conservatives said he's going to now
punish the people of california with
harsher lockdowns and he's doing it and
he's going to i mean right after the
election that's when la put in place
their
vax pass yeah rules they waited till
right after the election i i gotta be
honest i really do think that like
newsom was sitting in his office like
this you know looking at the tv and then
when cnn was like we caught a wolf
blitzer comes on it looks like a
landslide victory for newsome win
that's how i imagine the guy yeah that's
a really good evil villain laugh
i was just trying to imitate great
doctor doctor yeah
and then everyone around them is like
haha
they're laughing yeah that's that's how
i imagine it because now he's like
you know just imagine gavin newsom
looking over who's lieutenant governor
and he's like can we put more lockdowns
on los angeles let's punish the people
there let's make them like really hurt
that would be fine that's what de
blasio's doing i think that's
intentionally punishing new york city
did they ever get the sand out of the
skate park they didn't they did yeah
yeah that was cool i'm surprised
skateboarders didn't show up with like
leaf blowers start blowing it out but
they did go there and sweep and feel
like vacuum would be more effective yeah
but isn't it isn't it isn't it how like
how crazy is it that people still want
to live in these places
i guess the issue is
a dumb population is an easily
controlled population yeah i don't know
why anyone would willingly move to new
york at this point or california or
really any of those illinois
i was talking to a family member
and their my family's in chicago and
they said it's it's miserable it's awful
like it's it's worse than it's ever been
like is it a crime or is it no no it's
the lockdown there's lockdowns in
chicago yeah so it i don't know exactly
what's going on um but i have family in
the suburbs and they're like everyone's
like you you can't you can't go anywhere
without a mask they've got mandates
popping up all over the place the
schools are freaking out it's like
authoritarian nightmare in brooklyn it's
back to everybody walking around with
masks on outside yeah like fools and i'm
just walking around like a normal person
without my mask on because why because i
was i i've done the vaccination i've
done the thing that they said and it's
just it's never enough it's never going
to be enough let's talk about doing the
thing there's two americas right now
in new york people walk around outside
wearing masks in west virginia people
walk around outside wearing their ar-15s
which one would you want to live in no i
mean this seriously though obviously not
everybody in west virginia is walking
around with like a rifle and they're
like looking around but there are people
who do that we went to uh uh we were
driving through virginia and virginia's
not a good example but we're on our way
to central west virginia and there's
like people at restaurants and they're
strapped they got their guns and stuff
and so you think about the two different
americas the people in new york would
probably
scream and freak out they would freak
out yeah they would freak out like
there's that that photo of a guy and
he's got it you're not allowed to like
carry guns in new york you're not
allowed to have concealed you're not
allowed to carry on hopefully unless
unless you're an agent of the state
right
yeah
the cops are allowed to when i'm when
i'm in uh you know people have asked me
like if i was in west virginia and i saw
a guy walking around with like a bunch
of guns and like an ar-15 and like a
shotgun would you like run what would
you do and i'd be like i probably
wouldn't think anything at all
i i wouldn't i'm like a guy's got guns
now if he had like
carrying a ton of guns i would
especially not worry you know why he's
not gonna be able to move around
so like you see someone with a gun i'm
like i see people driving cars all the
time i never expect a car to veer off
the road and slam into me don't expect
the person to pull out a gun and shoot
at me i always expect the car to veer
off the road
and get me no that's new york i guess
right no i mean even just driving up
i've only had my license for like
literally a year
uh but yeah when i drive around i think
like it would be so easy to kill me
right now isn't that crazy people could
just go i used to when i was a kid i'd
be like what if everyone in the world
wanted all of a sudden just wanted to
kill me how long could i survive
like five yeah yeah there's no way no
we're so vulnerable we're incredibly
vulnerable creatures
that's why we need exo suits like
gundams
and that's what we should do all of the
profits from tim cast media will be
funneled into an r d project for
building the first mobile suit gundam
and then when the anti-photoshop to my
house i'll be like
fly off into space what it really means
is that we have to accept risk as a
component of existence we need to be
relatively fearless in the face of that
we need to know that we're going to die
that we can't just be protected all of
the time we need to accept that we need
to revel in it and we need to step out
our front doors
willingly and accept all of that you
know except that we're not safe and that
it's fine it's fine to not be safe yes
it's good to take risks if we don't take
risks that we have no remember this is
the issue is that of course we know that
of course the people watching know this
but the cult doesn't care no like they
want to win they want to crush you it's
fun look at what look at what they want
they want to go to school for they want
to
have secondary and whatever education
for free if they've paid for it they
want it to
they want that money back or they want
to not have to pay for it they want rent
to be fully covered they want the
government to pay out
uh money
endlessly if you don't have a job or if
you just don't want to get a job or
whatever they want to require businesses
to pay certain wages
um you know higher than the current
minimum wage they want to do all of
these things in order to
control society in order to regulate how
everybody is to live their lives
and there's no room to i mean where are
the artists going to come from where are
the
is going to come from where the explorer
is going to come from the left has
completely forgotten that in our hearts
we are a race fix
the left is a picasso painting
and the right is like an ikea
instruction pamphlet if what you're
saying is we have no conservative
culture you are correct yeah you know
what i mean that is an issue
the right is like
very straightforward and here's what we
believe here's why we believe it here's
what we want here's what we're to do and
then they kind of just like it's not
used it's it's tossed to the side and
then someone tries jamming the thing
together without actually crappy
materials and yes and the last is a
picasso painting where you're like i
think that's a person your policies are
a mishmash that come together and it's
not a readable document so i love that
the easiest example to understand why a
lot of a lot of uh leftist policies make
no sense uh we'll use the green new deal
when they started talking about a green
new deal i was like ooh oh i like how
this sounds what are you saying like
we'll allocate government funding from
like war
r d into like renewable energies maybe
oh would oh what if they start doing
infrastructure projects to
reduce our our dependence on foreign
foreign energy and things like that and
create uh maybe fusion ignition a green
new deal sounds pretty good a major jobs
project that works us towards energy
independence that'll make us more
that'll improve the economy and then aoc
comes out and goes free college and free
healthcare and and if you're if you're a
different if you're not white we'll give
it to you first and i'm like that that's
not a green
has anyone proposed a green new deal
like you just said no why
okay well well to be fair probably
but aoc's green new deal was like and
you'll get free college and people who
aren't white will get use reparations or
something like that i don't think she
actually said reparations but it was
like
identitarian free college then then then
you had on a website saying like we need
to stop air travel and farting cows and
i'm i'm not exaggerating literally said
farting cows and i'm like dude i made a
video where i was like a green new deal
sounds great
because we've been nation building in
other countries for so long we talked
about it here we were like what if we
did nation building in our own country
that would be actually kind of a green
new deal right instead what we get from
the progressives is this mishmash of
social justice trash that has nothing to
do with the environment but we also
don't know go ahead we don't get enough
from like like we said there hasn't been
a counter proposal that oh the right
obvious enough the republicans are
trashed exactly
the republicans are like the democrats
go we would like to infringe upon your
right to keep and bear arms and the
republicans just are like
no
don't don't
and then one by one more and more laws
come in and then you'll get these
republicans who are like
uh i i don't think it's a good bill and
we shouldn't we shouldn't pass a law
restricting infringing the rights to
keep and bear arms and then their aid
will lean them and go the new york times
just called you a nazi i i always wanted
to ban guns i was i was the first one
who wanted to do it and so
step by step our rights are being eroded
it's particularly second amendment
and republicans don't come out and say i
would like to repeal all the nfa like
where is the republican literally
marjorie taylor green lauren robert
lawrence can you please propose
repealing the nfa why won't even lauren
bober do that
she's like
like the prostate gun republican maybe
she has maybe i'm wrong but i certainly
think that you cannot be like nfa
i think a lot of this comes down to
there not being any conservative culture
i mean these values that you're talking
about
you know and i think freedom of speech
is actually
well under attack as well but it's
being attacked more from the corporate
side
fully backed by the federal government
but we don't have a conservative culture
movement that shows these values that
gives a voice to these concerns in a way
that uh shows up every day on people's
you know tick tock streams or no tv
shows or movies or in books or anywhere
you know we just don't see it i was um
listening to uh jack pasobic has a new
podcast and he was talking about his
children's book
um which is like an anti-communist book
for kids
we're at the point where we need
anti-communist books for kids
that's right
what is this you know and i think a lot
of this has to do with the failure of
the conservative movement to provide
entertainment options or anything that
people want to consume
i think people are correct i mean i'm
personally allergic to identifying left
or right in the first place i just i
can't make myself do it so and i think
that that's quite common with the youth
so you know
i agree with what you're saying but at
the same time i feel like the labels are
just dead
well no no let's be real i mean
all the forms are known left and right
are
they used to mean they sort of meant
something it was the french the french
from french parliament but i mean like
that on the left and people said on that
it's completely meaningless today
they're they're revolutionary yeah the
right were reactionaries opposing they
were they didn't want a revolution uh
it's it's it's tribal it's tribal
signifiers this point
if you are in favor of the democratic
establishment you are typically the left
if you are in opposition to the
establishment politics which includes
neocons republicans never trumpers then
you are on the right whether you believe
in right-wing politics or not it's
meaningless so basically i can be like
i'm pro-choice i would like universal
healthcare and they're like tim's
right-wing and i'm like tell me which
politician i would vote for in the
republican party if that's the case
because i was like chelsea gabbard and
andre yang seem all right and then
you know i have my criticisms of them as
well
i i would vote for rand paul because he
seems to be like the only principal well
i'm sorry that's not fair thomas
massie's pretty awesome too but there's
like very few actually principled people
in in government at all and then even
when i do look at people like ted cruz
or holly i'm like i just don't agree
outside of the liberty stuff so
politically homeless i guess but it
doesn't matter
if you believe in freedom
that's the right because you you'll see
this freedom is political and then
absolutely what was the new york times
headline
i don't know
they were saying like the the right-wing
freedom chanting
remember freedom they were in cuba they
were chanting right right right right
government yeah and then then the white
house was like they just they just want
more vaccines that's
what they're looking for
where is anybody on the actual left to
say mandating vaccines is wrong now
there have been some black lives matter
protesters saying vaccine mandates are
wrong legit weren't there some outside
the cdc in atlanta today i don't i don't
know
if they were black lives matter though
oh were they not yeah i don't know but
but they it was a bunch of young black
people who are protesting interesting
nicki minaj was correct fauci's lying so
what ends up happening is you do have
your overarching you know um
conservative inc and then you have
establishment left which includes
the the faux progressives these big
youtube channels and streamers who claim
to be on the left but then like buy
themselves extravagant houses or try to
union bust in their own companies so
left and right
you know what i don't know when someone
says something something because i'm on
the right jack said a couple times last
night i didn't say anything about it but
when they do that i'm here's my label
they've lost they've fallen in the swamp
and they sunk and they die you cannot
label yourself and get through this this
is not a
political all right cult or not cult
we'll do that cult or not and then
you've got to define the cult too yeah
so like do you challenge um narratives
who who was it was it mark twain that if
you find yourself on the majority you
should you know whatever this is
there are some things that i'm like i
believe this and i will stand by it and
uh that means i'm willing to criticize
high-profile individuals who might you
know uh be friends of mine or might have
you know certain access that would that
would i would benefit from but i'm not
gonna i'm not going to jim brewer best
example when he canceled his shows over
the vaccine mandate he was like i'm not
going to be beholden to the system of
money you know if to do something i
don't believe in and i'm like right on
jim
dude red red dude well this is why
language matters so much and like you
know huxley and orwell were obsessed
with it and it's just like we have to be
specific in the language because
obviously conservatism is a great
principle liberty liberalism should be a
great print like but those words i don't
want that no
i know they don't mean anything but i'm
just saying using them
is so limiting and that in the language
is being hijacked that's what's right
that's what's happening so we have to be
specific in the language that we're
using well yeah i mean it's interesting
too that even in our cultural
conversations we are
adhering to
a two-party system
well i mean i'm we i i think
the mises caucus guys are legit and
we've had dave smith here many many
times because they're they're like the
best we've got at this point and like
they're pro-life i i don't agree with
them a lot of things but i agree with
them on enough at least we can identify
a lot of the problems and i'm like if
the republicans won't even identify the
problems and the establishment democrats
are reveling in the problems i'll take
the the mises caucus guys who are at
least pointing to it that's bad here's
our plan i don't know if your plan is
going to work but at least you're going
to put the
it's like the republicans and democrats
are ignoring the fire or the democrats
are lighting the fire and the
libertarians like we got a plan to put
it out and i'm like i don't care what
your plan is do it dude that's why we
need to do things outside of politics
politics is
should really not be the the top thing
that we're dealing with i think politics
is irrelevant building technology you
know we should be making art why are we
not out there making more art yes
exactly
i miss making art it's what you do that
all the time you're doing it right now
you were just saying this about
conservatives though they're not
offering actually you both kind of made
a similar point you said where's the
conservative
uh rebuttal or offer after the democrats
do something and you said conservatives
aren't building they're not making art
and culture to inspire whatever right
that's it like the left has i'll tell
you
and art also doesn't need to be about
any of those things i mean your values
come through in the art that you create
because you are a principled individual
who believes in things and that
expresses with your heart that's a lot
of what we're trying to do with the new
shows we're launching it's not to make
political content to convince anybody of
any ideas but to tell stories that will
inspire and our values are conveyed
throughout i want to help teach people
how to cook
i actually want to learn how to cook
while i'm at it wait you're really doing
a cooking show
a couple days ago
another one went up yesterday i said you
want to avoid the sodium chloride and
use salt i meant sodium benzoate
sodium is salt thank you youtube
so check
i do think that there's a possibility of
a polar shift in in in culture
that prevents a total collapse
i still think it's most likely there is
a collapse but what i'm getting at is
when it comes to the creation of culture
the establishment is failing miserably
and it's getting worse and worse since
gamergate and comics gate and all this
stuff it has continually just been
rather bad in a lot of ways now some
stuff's shined through and been okay a
lot of stuff has been bad like the new
uh the craft remake which was actually
like a sequel and it made literally no
sense and it was just jamming at a bunch
of woke plot points that i'm very
confused by
and i'm like i don't understand like
they cast a spell to turn a guy gay a
lot of that stuff is just unwatchable
it's like watching those christian
productions we said this before like
flicks yeah pure flicks like i don't
know i don't know what a rag on purpose
i've been see i haven't seen it but it's
like those low grade like poorly
produced conserver bro like right
christian content that we used to make
fun
fun of like i think i think even sheamus
mentioned bible man and stuff yes and
it's like not inspiring kids don't kids
want to watch x-men
and now now now you know what i love
about x-men is the the the allusions to
civil rights right right but now the
left is latching on to that and making
x-men they're trying to make it like
woke the comics have definitely gotten
woke yeah they're doing like all marvel
wilkie stuff on disney and it's
it's it's it's sales are going down yeah
i really want a star trek
history shows didn't was it wasn't
wasn't discovery awoke i didn't watch it
yeah either no i just watched ds9 again
instead
about that era in star trek yes so so it
was like what 93 that launched
uh 89 the next generation i think the
next generation
88 yeah and then ds9 was like i think
93. yeah i think so and then it went
into like the late 90s and then they did
enterprise and it was just enterprise
was garbage yeah i had so much promise
too the great story scott bakula one of
my favorites i didn't want a sequel we
just had the dominion war come on yeah
and now we get these weird hokey pseudo
sequels i'll tell you picard was pretty
good i like picard and you can do
the social justice stuff right
but well the problem is look at the
social justice stuff that they did on
ds9 when benjamin cisco went back in
time and was uh
[Laughter]
nerding out yeah anyway but what
happened they did they went back in time
as san francisco and he was a sci-fi
writer and so he wrote a um he wrote a
story about a black space captain in the
future and the uh
publishers of the magazine said no we
can't run this with a black space
captain and they ended up deciding to
run it but it was a dream that it was a
black space captain
which you know there were so many layers
in there and that character
in the timeline ended up um in a mental
institution scribbling his stories on
the wall i mean it actually it was
transcendent it like transcended
it was just perfect deep space nine was
fantastic avery brooks was we got killer
we got recommended the episode i think
it's called in the pale moonlight and
it's where cisco stages
i'm forgetting but basically he stages a
conflict to force the romulans to enter
the war on the side of the federation
yeah and it's like
conspiracy evil stuff it's it's it's
that show was fantastic it was fantastic
and he was such a complicated captain i
look back at
i i thought about this i'm like pick
hard was good and for let me just stress
too if you're not a trekkie don't worry
like i want to keep this like you know
at the surface level
the new show that came out picard we're
doing a season i'm like it's a good show
but it was not profound yeah it was it
was not profound not thought provoking
not inspiring it didn't inspire me to do
anything it was like it's really fun to
see riker and picard hanging out
but when you watch the original star
trek
like
well that but mostly i think i like the
next generation better when you watch
the next generation it deals with the
philosophical consequences of
technological advancement and other
societies advancement stargate does that
really really well as well told me to
watch that i still have to watch that
it's it's not the same but it's similar
and it's like we had these shows in the
90s that were like here's a civilization
that dealt with that that you know
instead of inventing electricity they
discovered you know plasma or something
and then it's like how did how did they
develop what are their ideas
there's that really really really great
moment where data asks the card about
terrorism
and he says
something troubles me about you know
these people and their conduct and it's
you know we say terrorism is bad
yet it seems their strategies are
effective and often throughout history
we have seen these actions actually
bring about political change and picard
is like humans have been struggling with
these questions for generations and i do
not subscribe to the belief that
political power is derived from the
barrel of a gun and i'm like that was
like who are these writers who are just
like thought provoking philosophers
you don't you know also thinking of when
you hear about quotes from famous people
like ben franklin it's because only so
many of his words could actually be
translated through history could
actually be handed down because he would
write books he would write things but of
all of the words the man said probably
.001 percent of his ideas have made it
throughout history
today
you have these writers of these shows
building culture and giving these
profound ideas on like the make of a man
when when when data's on on when there's
trial determine whether it's a sentient
independent life form that's a great the
people who wrote that are brilliant
philosophers
and we're not going to take their names
and put the quotes down we're going to
put picard
data you know i think about the value
that tv and radio has given us as a
species and it's so great because it's
our ability to transmit information and
and like you said to pass the knowledge
down it's also created this danger where
you see hitler using the mass media to
brainwash the people and like how the
media today is kind of brainwashing so
but i think that the value outweighs
the danger so greatly so i imagine that
that's a very very good sign for a
species
do you think it's a coincidence that the
best memes came out of that
time of star trek
like all the memes that yeah the
internet are like yeah from that period
it's not surprising yeah you know what
you mentioned the 90s and i think the
90s to a certain extent were our reward
for
a difficult century uh there was so much
prosperity i remember there just being
um i was a kid basically i mean i was
like in my
late teens and in my 20s and there was
just money everywhere i remember this i
was like hanging out with a bunch of
visual artists everyone was getting paid
to do something ridiculous and instead
was blowing it all on
it was the dinner and strippers and
stuff we had a great time uh but yeah
that was like the reward it was a
cultural reward there was art everywhere
there was amazing music came out of that
era
we had an awful lot of equality we had
an awful lot of um
equality between the sexes women could
do whatever they wanted
the internet merged and then the dot-com
just went too far well i think i think a
lot of it too was um you know september
11th we had like a massive terrorist
attack it was shortly thereafter and
that kind of
that made everything crazy it was the
cold war dividend cold war ended and all
of a sudden we were like what do we do
with all this money and all these
resources and all these plans and all
these troops we had a lot of we made a
lot of art in the 90s there was really
good visual art came out but then
china started to emerge as a greater
power
and then you had a bunch of problems
here in the u.s like the appeal of
glass-steagall and then the economic
crisis
and now china's getting more and more
power and now perhaps one of the biggest
issues is that we as a nation have no
ability to stop china from taking over
as the global superpower and global
economic power and it's just like the
u.s at this point is has become too
feeble to fight back as a nation yeah
but not as people we do oh go ahead
i think with crypto and and local
governance we can do it but no no yeah
that that's that's great we'll have
small pockets of independent
freedom-loving people who are tending to
their chickens which is fine but china
will be
dominating the culture of the planet
like the us did for so long
then they'll start putting out their
ideas of why freedom is bad and it's
already happening we're already starting
to adopt more of the the chinese
communist style governance and political
control oh i just saw a story that the
chinese are going to start doing social
credit on corporations now yes that's
correct i saw that too that's wild
welcome to the description and they're
also they're also regulating content a
lot more now too that's a whole big
thing yeah they banned kids from playing
video games yeah yeah hour and night or
so three hours a week
but even though they banned bitcoin
mining in china it's not going to stop
the people of china from rapidly
adopting it i mean the like
you can't just assume that there's you
know monoculture in terms of the the
thought process of the of the citizens
of china like crypto is still going to
dominate that makes sense that you know
the people are not homogeneous in terms
of their perspective but
they are showing themselves to be
relatively squashable
hong kong is not hong kong anymore um
you know there's a genocide going on and
pelosi i think from that same interview
that you pulled up earlier
she was saying that yes china is
committing genocide against the uyghurs
but it's more important that we team up
with them about climate change
we're idiots like for letting this kind
of thing happen china also though had a
long period of time while
uh the west was engaging in the age of
exploration and all of that where they
were basically just isolationists
um the u.s i think should have a lot
more ability to control its own destiny
in terms of
energy independence in terms of
manufacturing independence
one thing trump did was he tried to get
more pharmaceutical production in the us
localized in the us which i think
obviously we should be doing why are we
you know for for
decades we let
so many asian countries basically be the
factories of the us and the factories of
u.s
corporations and u.s commerce and
there's no reason to keep doing that we
got gutted
i mean except that americans probably
don't want to work any of these jobs
what with the free money being
but
it's going to be a cold splash of water
in the face when americans who do these
tr like these these fake jobs like
like i tell that story when i first went
to vice and saw how much people were
getting paid and what they did for a
living i was like wow
if working class people in this country
could see inside new york media they
would there would be a revolution
overnight
could you imagine working fifteen
dollars an hour doing doing labor only
to discover that someone's getting paid
50 an hour to like scour the internet
for pictures of a celebrity
and then they they don't show up half
the time right they don't show up and
they don't got to go to work i'm not
kidding yeah the vice office would be
like empty half the time and i'd be like
oh where is you know someone's me about
home
they'll just still write something i
guess i can only imagine the
conversations they have like the board
of directors cnn like when they're
behind the scenes at msnbc if if we had
access to that we got to listen in on
that
yeah i think there would be a revolution
overnight the issue i'm bringing up is
that there are people who work hard
every single day and they come home with
calloused hands sweat pouring you know
drenched in sweat and they sit down and
their back hurts and they go to the
doctor and the doctor is like jim you
got a slip disk
and he's like
getting paid you know 40 grand a year
doing the stuff and it's like he's he's
his body is is in pain then there are
guys who it's like they finally got that
promotion they're working really really
hard and they they're older and then
there's a 20 year old getting paid
double their salary in new york to
complain about you for voting for donald
trump and they say you're a [ __ ] you're
a dumb ass you're so stupid and that
guy's breaking his back to build the
infrastructure in this company every one
of these construction guys who was out
in
interdirection
and to like bring your stuff and then
they say you're a maggot and a plague
and they get double the money you make
i i find it still so shocking because it
was it's what like
the country's basically half and half at
this point it was like what 74 million
people voted for trump
uh the other half kind of voted for the
other guy yeah voted against trump right
voted against trump that's only what
they did but then also the thing with
the uh i think there's been a number of
polls coming out recently showing that
it's like 51 of americans are in favor
of vaccine mandates and 49 or not i know
that that's one poll i saw so it's def
it's definitely like half and half and
one half of the country is telling the
other half of the country that they're
garbage and that that half of the
country they don't even doing all of the
work thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you